This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantin. Whether or not you believe in them, you probably have ghosts that hunt you. Not something sinister, but something that you just can't get rid of. These ghosts are relentless and they will make you rehash details from your past, over and over again. Hello, Sean Carr and friends. Hello, Sean Carr. Hi. I was calling about, also, I sang it,
这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹丁。不管你信不信，你可能都有挥之不去的“心魔”。倒不是什么邪恶的东西，而是一些你无法摆脱的事物。这些心魔挥之不去，会让你一遍又一遍地咀嚼过去的细节。你好，肖恩·卡尔和朋友们。你好，肖恩·卡尔。嗨。我打电话来也是想说，我唱了，
records I've had a few, so I won't list all of them. My boyfriend of a year and I end up in a relationship. It's just looking back and thinking that I could have done better. And I didn't. All these things keep popping in my head of small things. Maybe something I should have said differently or something I should have done differently in a particular conversation or on a particular event. It makes me cringe with regret and shame. I haven't a fair. I don't know that it's not a secret, but it's a regret. My great regret is leaving Woodstock on Saturday morning. I was an evangelical Christian at
我出过几张唱片，所以我不会把它们全列出来。我和交往了一年的男友最终走到了一起。回想起来，总觉得我本可以做得更好。但我没有。脑海里不断涌现出各种细碎的事情。也许有些话我本该换种方式说，或者在某个特定的对话中、某次特定的活动中，有些事我本该换种方式做。这让我感到羞愧和遗憾。我没做过。我不知道这算不算秘密，但这确实是个遗憾。我最大的遗憾是周六早上离开伍德斯托克。我当时是一个福音派基督徒，
the time and I remember my friends asking me if I thought they were going to hell. And I told them that I thought they would go to hell if they did not become Christian. And it's something that's bothered me for the last 10 years. I am experiencing regrets on sometimes a minute by minute basis. And it is the biggest regret of my life, honestly. I hope you have a great rest of your day. Bye. Today on Hidden Brain, we're going to talk about regrets.
我记得朋友们问我，我是否认为他们会下地狱。我告诉他们，如果他们不成为基督徒，他们就会下地狱。这件事在过去的十年里一直困扰着我。我有时甚至每分每秒都在体验着遗憾。老实说，这是我一生中最大的遗憾。祝你们今天过得愉快。再见。今天在“隐藏的大脑”节目中，我们要聊聊遗憾。
Amy Samolville is a psychology professor at Miami University of Ohio. She runs the regret lab where she studies how people think about the choices they made and the choices they wish they'd made. Amy, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi, it's great to talk to you. You know, I was fascinated when I heard that you run a regret lab and I was fascinated when I heard that you run a regret lab. I was fascinated because I was wondering, what prompt someone to spend so much time studying regret? What drew you to the subject?
艾米·萨莫尔维尔是迈阿密大学俄亥俄分校的心理学教授。她负责“遗憾实验室”，在那里研究人们如何看待自己做出的选择以及他们希望自己曾做出的选择。艾米，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。嗨，很高兴和你交谈。你知道，当我听说你运营一个遗憾实验室时，我感到非常着迷。我感到着迷是因为我在想，是什么促使一个人花这么多时间研究遗憾呢？是什么吸引你进入这个领域的？
I don't know that I have a particular deep backstory about how I got into regret. I actually was just generally interested in social psychology. One of the things that then drew me to regret from that is the fact that regret is among our most common emotions. By some estimates, it's the second most common emotion mentioned in daily life, and the most common negative emotion that we mention. And so this is really a pervasive part of how people experience the world around them. And as I learned more, I really started to realize that
我不知道我进入遗憾领域有没有什么特别深厚的背景故事。其实我只是对社会心理学普遍感兴趣。吸引我关注遗憾的原因之一是，遗憾是我们最普遍的情绪之一。据估计，它是日常生活中被提及频率第二高的情绪，也是我们提及频率最高负面情绪。因此，这确实是人们体验周围世界的一个无处不在的部分。随着我了解的深入，我开始意识到，
regret is actually a very hopeful emotion. It's something that is helping us learn from our mistakes and do better in the future. So it's actually, I think, a really positive thing to get to study. Amy, I'd like to structure this conversation around a couple of stories of regret. We actually reached out to listeners of Hidden Brain some time ago and they sent in stories
遗憾其实是一种非常充满希望的情绪。它能帮助我们从错误中吸取教训，在未来做得更好。所以我觉得，研究这个其实是一件非常积极的事情。艾米，我想围绕几个关于遗憾的故事来展开今天的对话。其实我们不久前联系了“隐藏的大脑”的听众，他们发来了一些故事，
about some of the things they regret in life. One came from Tom Bond's saint of Arlington, Virginia. Here's the tip. I regret not taking the lead in a school play when I was in ninth grade. I was in a nine through twelve school and I was surprised to receive a lead as a freshman. It was somewhat of a big deal, considering that freshmen typically don't get those sort of roles.
讲述了他们在生活中遗憾的一些事。其中一个来自弗吉尼亚州阿灵顿的汤姆·邦德圣。这是他的留言。我后悔在九年级时没有在学校话剧里争取主角。我当时在一所九到十二年级的学校，作为一名新生能得到主角，我感到很惊讶。考虑到新生通常不会得到那种角色，这算是一件大事。
And rather than accept the fact that the director felt like I would be a good choice for the role, I listened to people who said that I probably couldn't handle it and therefore decided to turn the role down. Later on in life life I realized that when people present me with an opportunity like that, if they have the confidence in me being able to be successful, they're likely not putting me in that place to fail. And so, since then, I feel like I've gotten a new confidence. And so, when faced with a similar situation
我没有接受导演认为我会是这个角色好人选的事实，而是听信了那些说我可能应付不来的人的话，因此决定放弃这个角色。后来在生活中我意识到，当人们给我提供这样的大机会时，如果他们对我有信心并认为我能成功，他们很可能不会把我放在会失败的位置上。所以，从那以后，我觉得自己获得了新的自信。因此，当面对类似的情况时，
in the current dice, I've been much more likely to put my hand up and say yes. I'm wondering how common this is. Are people really good at taking what happened in the past and learning from it? What spells the difference between people who actually are behaving like Tom taking a bad experience and saying, I'm actually going to use it and people who just sort of stay stuck in what that bad experience was and think about it over and over again? So I think the thing that really characterizes it is less about necessarily what kind of person you are,
现在的我更有可能举手说“好”。我想知道这有多普遍？人们真的很擅长吸取过去发生的事情并从中吸取教训吗？那些真正像汤姆那样吸取糟糕经历并说“我要利用它”的人，与那些只停留在那种糟糕经历中并一遍又一遍地思考的人，到底有什么区别呢？所以我认为真正具有特征性的东西，与其说取决于你是什么样的人，
but rather the way that you're experiencing these thoughts. So there's something called rumination, which actually comes literally from bovine digestion, the idea of how cows vomit back up things, chew them over, swallow them back down, and so on and so forth. And in terms of our thoughts, it's actually this idea of the same kind of process that rumination is having thoughts sort of spring unwanted to mind and we're chewing them over without actually getting anything new out of them. They're just repeatedly, intrusively becoming sort of part of our mental landscape. And what we found is that people who have roominative regrets, so that they're both having this regret, but also having it be something that's intrusive and repeated
不如说取决于你体验这些想法的方式。有一种东西叫反刍思维，它实际上字面意思源自牛的消化过程，也就是牛把东西吐出来、重新咀嚼、再吞下去等等的过程。就我们的想法而言，它其实就是这种过程——反刍思维会让不请自来的想法突然冒出来，我们在没有从中获得任何新东西的情况下反复咀嚼它们。它们只是反复地、侵入式地成为我们精神世界的一部分。我们发现，那些有反刍性遗憾的人——也就是说，他们既有这种遗憾，但这种遗憾又具有侵入性和重复性——
tend to be people who are also experiencing the most negative outcomes. So, are more likely to have clinical depression symptoms, anxiety symptoms, things like that. There are some regrets you can learn from, like Tom's story about trying out for the school play, but other regrets feel harder to overcome. I asked Amy some of her about this, and I played her the story from Catherine Wiginton Green, a listener from Washington, D.C. played her the story from Catherine Wiginton Green, a listener from Washington DC. My main regret, what popped into my mind when I heard this on the podcast, was regretting not stopping and seeing my estranged father. He'd been estranged for our family for quite a while, and I had not seen him or spoken
往往也是那些经历最负面结果的人。所以，他们更有可能患有临床抑郁症症状、焦虑症状等等。有些遗憾你可以从中吸取教训，比如汤姆关于试镜学校话剧的故事，但有些遗憾感觉更难克服。我问过艾米关于这方面的一些看法，并播放了一位来自华盛顿特区的听众凯瑟琳·威金顿·格林的故事。我最大的遗憾，当我听到播客里讲到这个时脑海中浮现的，是后悔没有停下来去看望我疏远的父亲。他疏远了我们家好长一段时间，我既没有见过他，也没有和他说过话，
with him in a very long time, his choice. I was driving along Barcwade Parkway,way with my boyfriend at the time, who was now my husband. As we were driving up Barcree Parkway, I looked to my right and saw him and the woman he married walking arm in arm. I saw him and I told my husband to pull over immediately without thinking. When we stopped the car, I started to unbuckle my seatbelt. And then I stopped and paused for a moment and realized, I had no idea what I was going to do or what I was going to say.
这是他的选择。当时我正和当时的男友、也就是现在的丈夫开车行驶在巴克韦德公园大道上。当我们沿着巴克韦德公园大道行驶时，我向右看去，看到他和他的妻子挽着手臂走着。我看到了他，毫不犹豫地叫我丈夫马上靠边停车。当我们停下车时，我开始解安全带。然后我停顿了一会儿，突然意识到，我根本不知道自己要做什么或说什么。
So I chickened out and buckled my seatbelt back and told my husband to keep driving. And then I burst into tears. And I realized that that was probably the last time I was in the scene here, and that was my only chance to talk to him again. So I still regret that. There's something really point in about that story, Amy, because in this case, it doesn't sound as if the regret has the potential for learning.
所以我退缩了，又把安全带系好，叫我丈夫继续开车。接着我失声痛哭起来。我意识到那可能是我最后一次见到他，那是我和他再次交谈的唯一机会。所以我至今仍然后悔。艾米，那个故事里有些非常触动人心的东西，因为在这种情况下听起来，这个遗憾似乎并不具备学习的潜力。
She says that she feels that the door was closed in terms of her ability to reconnect with her father, and she comes back to this memory over and over again, and just remembers it as an opportunity that was lost. Yeah, certainly in terms of the specific incidents that we regret, they do seem to be most likely things where we had this opportunity in the moment, but it's not something that we can go back and fix. Because obviously, if we could just magically turn back and fix something, then most people would do that
她说她觉得在能够与父亲重新建立联系这方面，大门已经关闭了。她一次又一次地回到这段记忆中，只是把它当成了一个失去的机会。是的，确实，就我们遗憾的具体事件而言，它们似乎最有可能发生在我们在当时有这个机会，但却无法回头去修复的事情上。因为很明显，如果我们能像变魔术一样倒回并修复某件事，那么大多数人都会那样做，
rather than continue to regret it. What I might say is that I would imagine that one of the reasons that this does wrinkle for this woman is that it's about something that's important to her that it's about something that's important to her, it's about her family. And that perhaps this is something that she can carry forward in terms of how she handles other relationships going forward. So I've heard people say that there are anecdotal reports that the things that people really
而不是继续去遗憾。我想说的是，这位女士之所以对此耿耿于怀，原因之一可能在于，这件事对她来说非常重要，它关乎她的家庭。也许这件事可以让她在未来如何处理其他关系时作为一种借鉴。所以我听说过一些传言，据非正式报告显示，人们真正遗憾的事情，
regret are the things that they didn't do rather than the things that they did do. Is that just anecdotal? Is that not actually true that people regret acts of omission more than acts of commission? I would say there's some evidence for that. So one of the more famous studies on this thought about this in terms of something that happens over time. And what those researchers argued is that we regret things we did a lot more in the moment. So if you say something really stupid in a job interview, you're going to walk out and have that hand to the forehead feeling of,
往往是他们没有做的事，而不是他们做过的事。这仅仅是传言吗？人们对“不作为”的遗憾真的比对“作为”的遗憾更多吗？这其实是有一定证据的。关于这一点，其中一项比较著名的研究是从时间推移的角度来思考的。那些研究人员认为，我们在当下的那一刻，对做过的事情会感到更多的遗憾。如果你在求职面试中说了句极其愚蠢的话，你走出去时会做出扶额的动作，心里会想：
oh, why did I say that? That was such a terrible thing to have said in that moment. But in the long run, we tend to have things that are kind of incomplete goals stick around in our memory as kind of a mental to-do list, basically. And that as a result, our inactions wind up getting kind of added to that mental to-do list. So this may be something where, if you ask me, you know, what could you have done instead of going to grad school? I have this whole range of possibilities. I could have been a doctor. I could have been a writer. I could have backpacked around Europe and found my passion.
“我刚才为什么要说那种话？在那种情况下说这种话简直太糟糕了。”但从长远来看，那些未竟的目标往往会作为一种心理“待办清单”长期留在我们的记忆中。因此，结果就是我们的不作为最终会被加入到那个心理待办清单中。所以这可能是这样一种情况：如果你问我，“你当时除了去读研究生还能做什么？”我有整整一堆可能性。我本可以当医生。我本可以当作家。我本可以去欧洲背包旅行并找到我的热情所在。
And if you ask me, what are the things that you did yesterday that you could undo? I have a finite set of things I actually did in my life. And so over time, it may be that when we're trying to undo something bad that's happened to us, it's easy to start imagining all of the things we might have done in the past because we have a lot more of those available to us than the things we actually did. There are times when we don't take responsibility for our actions, but at other times, we hold ourselves accountable for things
如果你问我，“你昨天做过的事情里有哪些是你可以撤销的？”我在生活中实际做过的事情其实是有限的。所以随着时间的推移，当我们试图撤销已经发生的坏事时，我们很容易开始想象过去所有可能做过的事情，因为比起我们实际做过的事，我们脑海中有更多这种未完成的选项。有时候我们不为自己的行为负责，但另一些时候，我们会为那些超出我们控制范围的事情承担责任。
that are outside our control. James Cooper of Pittsburgh shared one of those stories for us. My biggest regret is not listening to my father tell me about the mundane things that happened to him during the day. And instead just immediately asking for my mom when I called the house,
来自匹兹堡的詹姆斯·库珀给我们分享了这样一个故事。我最大的遗憾是没有听父亲跟我讲他白天发生的那些琐事，而是一打电话回家就立刻找我妈妈，
and maybe when I talked to him, I could have picked up on some other signs too, and could have maybe prevented his suicide. You know, when I heard James's story, Amy, I wondered whether, you know, if he had spoken to his father more, would he have actually picked up on his father's mental health? And even if he had noticed, could he have actually stopped his father from committing suicide?
也许当我跟他谈心时，我也能捕捉到其他的一些迹象，或许本可以阻止他的自杀。你知道，当我听到詹姆斯的的故事时，艾米，我在想，如果他当时跟父亲多聊聊，他真的能察觉到父亲的心理健康状况吗？即便他注意到了，他真的能阻止父亲自杀吗？
And it seemed to me that in this case, James might have been taking on more responsibility than was actually warranted. I mean, it's understandable, certainly at an emotional level, but you've done some research looking at how sometimes when it comes to regret, we take on more responsibility than we should. Yeah, I think I would say exactly that. I think that this is a case of probably imagining that there's more that could have happened differently. And it's certainly the case as well that I think people often tend to focus a lot on their own actions about negative
在我看来，在这种情况下，詹姆斯可能承担了本不该由他承担的责任。我的意思是，从情感层面来说这当然是可以理解的，但你做过一些研究，发现有时在面对遗憾时，我们会承担比应尽更多的责任。是的，我想我完全同意这一点。我认为这是一个很典型的例子，人们可能会想象如果事情有不同的发展本可以如何。而且很显然，人们也常常倾向于将注意力集中在自己对负面事件所采取的行动上，
events. And it's probably important to think about the fact that you're just one agent in a much bigger framework, that his father had other friends, hopefully had doctors, had his mother, and that it's not just on James to have recognized these symptoms, but that there were lots of other pieces that could have played out differently, not just his own actions, but a broader set of things that could have changed. Is there a way for people to look at their regrets and say, this is the kind of regret that is actually useful and productive, and this is the kind of regret that is actually better set aside?
但同样重要的是，我们要认识到你其实只是更大框架中的一个行动者，他的父亲还有其他朋友，希望还有医生和母亲，而且不应该全由詹姆斯一个人来识别这些症状，还有很多其他的因素本来可以有不同的走向——不仅仅是他自己的行为，还有更广泛的一系列可能发生改变的事情。人们有没有办法审视自己的遗憾，然后说：“这种遗憾实际上是有用且富有成效的，而这种遗憾其实最好抛开？”
So, yeah, I would say that we know that people tend to generate these what-if thoughts as a way of trying to understand their experiences and as a way of trying to bring control to things that feel uncontrollable. We don't like the idea that bad things happen with no reason and without the ability to predict them. And in the case of regret, I think it can be that in James's case, for instance, not wanting to think about this tremendous loss as something that wasn't predictable and wasn't controllable, that it's I think very reassuring sometimes to try to come up with an explanation of there's a way that this could have been prevented, it could have been changed, and it feels less random and less senseless in that way.
是的，我的意思是，我们知道人们倾向于产生这些“如果……会怎样”的想法，以此作为试图理解自己经历的一种方式，并试图对那些感觉无法控制的事情施加控制。我们不喜欢坏事无缘无故发生且无法预测的想法。就遗憾而言，我认为在詹姆斯的例子中，比如不希望把这种巨大的损失看作是无法预测和无法控制的，有时试着给出一个解释——即这件事本可以被阻止、本可以被改变——会让人感到非常安心，这样它看起来就没那么随机，也没那么毫无意义了。
You know, I'm fascinated by what you just said because essentially what you're saying is that the fear or the pain of having a world that seems, you know, without meaning or is unexplainable or unpredictable, that pain of that might actually be greater than the pain of taking on regrets for things that you actually maybe don't have responsibility for and experiencing personal anguish
你知道，你刚才说的话让我非常着迷，因为你本质上是在说：一个看似毫无意义、无法解释或无法预测的世界所带来的恐惧或痛苦，这种痛苦实际上可能大于为那些你可能并不需要承担责任的事情承担遗憾并经历个人痛苦的痛苦。
about it, that's a fascinating idea. Yeah, there's been research that says one of the ways that people can get a sense of control over their circumstances is by having these thoughts about what might have been. The dark side of that, along with personal regret, is there is also work where things like victim blaming can actually come out of these thoughts about what might have been. So if you think about a woman who attended a party and drank a drink that had been drugged
关于这个，真是个迷人的想法。是的，有研究表明，人们掌控自己境况的一种方式，就是去思考“如果当时……会怎样”。其阴暗面，除了个人遗憾之外，还有一些研究发现，诸如受害者谴责之类的现象，实际上也源于这种“如果当时……会怎样”的想法。所以，如果你想象一个女人去参加派对，喝了一杯被下药的饮料
and then was sexually assaulted. It's very easy to think about that one moment of she took this drink and if she had been more careful, then this assault might not have happened to her and that that sort of gives us a sense of control rather than the much more complicated thing to think about undoing of, well, how could we have prevented this person who gave her this drink and who committed this crime from doing it? So, yeah, these thoughts about what might have been
然后遭到了性侵。人们很容易把那一瞬间归结为：她喝了这杯饮料，如果她当时更小心一点，那么这次性侵可能就不会发生在她身上。这种想法给我们带来了一种掌控感，比起去思考那些更复杂的事情——比如，我们该如何阻止那个给她下药、犯下罪行的人？所以，是的，这些关于“如果当初”的想法
help give us a causal structure to our world, but sometimes they're not necessarily the correct or the most useful ways of thinking about causality. When we come back, a story of regret and karma. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Back with Amy Somerville, she's a psychologist in head of the regret lab at Miami University of Ohio. Amy, let's listen to another story. This one comes from Tanya Stock of Farmington, New Mexico. I'm going to play the story in two parts because I think it reveals two different sides of regret. One of my biggest regrets comes from something I did in the fifth grade,
帮助我们建立对世界的因果结构认知，但有时它们不一定是正确或最有用的因果思考方式。稍后回来，我们将为您讲述一个关于遗憾和因果报应的故事。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。欢迎回到艾米·萨莫维尔的访谈，她是迈阿密大学俄亥俄分校遗憾实验室的心理学家。艾米，让我们听另一个故事。这个故事来自新墨西哥州法明顿的托尼娅·斯托克。我打算分两部分播放这个故事，因为我认为它揭示了遗憾的两个不同侧面。我最大的遗憾之一源于我在五年级时做的一件事，
20 or more years ago. I remember making fun of this little girl who was a bit overweight in me and another girl just teased her relentlessly. And I think about some of the things that I said to her and some of the ways that I treated her. And I just regret how cruel I was as a child. And now that I'm older and I work in a field where I see the effects of bullying and meanness does to children. I am so full of regret in that and if I could ever find her again or talk to her again because I've moved to three or four different places at this point in my life and have no idea where she is or if it even affected her, I regret
20多年前的事了。我记得当时取笑一个小女孩，她比我胖一点，我和另一个女孩无休止地捉弄她。我回想起我对她说的一些话，以及我对待她的某些方式。我只是为自己小时候的残忍感到遗憾。现在我长大了，我从事的领域让我看到了霸凌和恶意对孩子们造成的负面影响。对此我充满了遗憾，如果我还能找到她或者再次和她说话的话——因为我在人生的这个阶段已经搬了三四次家了，根本不知道她在哪里，也不知道这是否对她造成了影响——我为
the way that I treated her and I believe that I was so cruel. Amy, I want to talk about the role of guilt in regret. They seem closely tied these two emotions, but I don't think they're identical. Tom Bonsain from Arlington, Virginia, regretted that he didn't get the lead in his school play, but there was no guilt involved. Tanya, on the other hand, feels terrible about what she did. When you hear Tanya's story, are you hearing guilt or are you hearing regret? So listening to Tanya's story, I would say I hear both guilt and regret, and both regret and guilt are emotions that are based on a form of comparison. So regret, I'm comparing what really happened to some imagined alternative.
我对待她的方式感到遗憾，我相信我当时太残忍了。艾米，我想谈谈遗憾中内疚的作用。这两种情感似乎紧密相连，但我认为它们并不完全相同。来自弗吉尼亚州阿灵顿的汤姆·邦森遗憾自己没有在学校话剧里当上主角，但这其中并不涉及内疚。而托尼娅则对自己的所作所为感到十分糟糕。当你听到托尼娅的故事时，你听到的是内疚还是遗憾？所以听了托尼娅的故事，我想说我既听到了内疚也听到了遗憾，遗憾和内疚都是基于某种形式的比较。就遗憾而言，我是把现实中发生的事情与某种想象中的替代方案进行比较。
And some of the time, that's all we feel, right? I just imagined that something could have been better. Guilt involves an additional comparison to what has been called our personal standards rules and goals. So what are the things that we aspire to in our behavior? And when we make a comparison that says, what we really did, fall short of those personal standards, rules, or goals for ourselves, then we're likely to feel guilt.
有时候，这就是我们的全部感受，对吧？我只是想象事情本可以更好。而内疚则包含了一种额外的比较，即与我们所谓的个人标准、规则和目标的比较。也就是说，我们在行为上有哪些追求？当我们进行比较，发现我们的实际行为未能达到我们对自己设定的那些个人标准、规则或目标时，我们就很可能会感到内疚。
I want you to listen to the second part of Tanya's story. She told us that she fully realized what she had done to this other little kid, only when events in her own life took a turn. I think karma came and got me because while I was a petite little kid as I got older and through some injuries, I became quite overweight myself and heard the comments that were said about me or how I became invisible and like people didn't think that my feelings mattered. The heaviest I ever was was 330 pounds and I have worked hard and have surgery and have lost. Quite a bit of weight, I'm just about 195 now, but I still see myself and still have the self-confidence of a 330 pound woman. I know how it feels and I regret making anyone else ever feel that way. When you listen to Tanya's story Amy, I'm wondering, do you hear sort of someone saying, I really don't like the way the world is treated me or do you hear someone saying,
我想让你听听托尼娅故事的第二部分。她告诉我们，只有当她自己的人生经历发生转变时，她才真正意识到自己对那个小女孩做了什么。我觉得报应找上门了，因为虽然我小时候是个娇小的小孩，但随着年龄增长以及经历了一些伤病，我自己也变得相当胖，也听到了别人对我的评论，或者感受到了自己如何变得像隐形人一样，仿佛人们觉得我的感受根本不重要。我最重的时候达到了330磅，我努力过，做过手术，也减掉了。相当多的体重，现在我大概195磅，但我看自己时依然带着330磅胖女人的自卑。我知道那种感觉，我为自己曾让任何人有过那种感受而感到遗憾。当你听到托尼娅的故事时，艾米，我在想，你听到的是某人在说“我真的很不喜欢世界这样对待我”，还是听到有人在说，
I realize the world is treated me really badly and that's opened my eyes to the way that I might have treated other people in the past. It sounds like in Tanya's case, she's really developed a different understanding of the world and used that to understand how her behavior may have affected other people rather than necessarily being a particularly focused on feeling that she's been treated badly. And I think that again, regret is based on this idea that we personally could have done something differently. And so in some ways, it's obviously a self-focused emotion. It's about what we should have done, but I think it can also be a fairly selfless emotion
“我意识到世界对我很不好，这让我睁开眼睛，看到了我过去可能那样对待别人的方式。”听起来在托尼娅的Vcase中，她确实对世界有了不同的理解，并以此来理解她的行为可能如何影响了其他人，而不是特别纠结于自己受到了不公对待。我认为，遗憾再次建立在这样一个观点之上：我们本可以通过不同的方式做点什么。所以从某种程度上说，这显然是一种自我关注的情感。它是关于我们本该做什么，但我认为它也可以是一种相当无私的情感
and be about how we relate to the people in the world around us, what responsibility do we have towards our fellow humans? One of the things that I really hear Tanya talking about is I wish that I could find this person and tell her about how I now regret what I did to her when we were children. And I think one of the things as well that's interesting about this whole episode is that you have listeners calling in to tell the whole world, millions of people who might listen to this podcast about their very personal, very private regrets. You know, psychologists have talked for a long time about something called the fundamental
并且关乎我们如何与周围世界的人建立联系，我们对同胞负有什么责任？托尼娅谈话中让我印象深刻的一点是，她希望自己能找到这个人，告诉她我现在多么后悔我们小时候对她做的事。我认为关于这一整集，另一个有趣的地方在于，有听众打电话来，向全世界、可能数百万收听这个播客的人，倾诉他们非常个人、非常私密的遗憾。你知道，心理学家讨论了很久一个叫做“基本归因
attribution era, which is how much do we believe actions of either ourselves or others are caused by things that are intrinsic to us, things that are part of our personalities, who we are, versus things that are shaped by the context, by the situation in which we find ourselves. When someone like Tanya looks back as an adult at her behavior as a child, do you think the fundamental attribution at her plays a role in some ways leading us to believe that we are responsible for things that maybe we were not responsible for, that maybe really the context was driving our actions and behavior way back when. Yeah, absolutely.
错误”的概念，也就是我们多大程度上认为自己或他人的行为是由内在事物引起的——比如我们的个性、我们是谁，还是由环境、我们所处的情境塑造的？当像托尼娅这样的人作为一个成年人回首她作为孩子的行为时，你认为基本归因错误在某种程度上是否导致我们相信自己要对某些可能并不由我们负责的事情承担责任？或许当时确实是环境在驱使我们的行动和行为。是的，完全是这样。
and behavioral way back where? Yeah, absolutely. Again, I think regret is based on this sense of personal responsibility. And certainly in Western cultures, there's very much this belief that individuals are responsible for their own actions, we're responsible for our own destinies. And I think that can lead individuals to think more about how a given actor, including themselves or including another person played a role, and a lot less attention to the whole context.
行为在很久以前？是的，完全是这样。再次说明，我认为遗憾是建立在个人责任感的基础上的。当然，在西方文化中，很大程度上存在这样一种信念：个人要为自己的行为负责，我们要为自己的命运负责。我认为这可能会导致人们更多地思考某个行动者（包括他们自己或另一个人）是如何发挥作用的，而对整个宏观环境的关注则要少得多。
So in Tanya's story, I believe she started by talking about how there was another little girl that she was friends with who joined with her in the bullying. And I think it may be easy to ignore the degree to which she was experiencing peer pressure. Right? There was probably a social context in which this bullying occurred, which doesn't forgive it or excuse it, but it's not necessarily just about who Otonia is as a person to have done this, but rather really a much more complicated net of things that were influencing her as well as who she was at that time. I want to talk about the idea of counterfactuals. A counterfactual of course is when we imagine that things could have turned out differently than they actually did.
所以在托尼娅的故事中，我相信她一开始提到过，有一个和她一起参与霸凌的小女孩。我认为我们可能很容易忽视她当时承受同辈压力的程度。对吧？这种霸凌发生时很可能存在某种社会环境，这虽然不能原谅或开脱她的行为，但这并不完全关乎托尼娅作为一个怎样的人做出了这种事，而是一个更复杂的网络，既影响了当时的她，也塑造了当时的她。我想谈谈反事实思维的概念。反事实思维当然是指我们想象事情的结局本可以与实际不同的情况。
As it turns out, I'm recovering right now from a sports injury and when I think about how I got hurt, the only thing I'm thinking about is what could I have done differently to prevent this injury from happening? Now most of the time when I play sports, I'm not asking myself why didn't I get hurt? So what do you think causes us to reach for certain counterfactuals at one point in time, but not for others? So we talk about counterfactuals as having two different directions. So things imagining how the world could have been better, we call upward counterfactuals and imagining how the world could have been worse, we call downward counterfactuals. And certainly in life, upward counterfactuals seem to predominate.
事实证明，我目前正在从运动损伤中恢复，当我回想自己是如何受伤的时候，我唯一想到的就是我当时可以做些什么不同的事情来防止这次受伤的发生？现在我大部分时间在进行体育运动时，我不会问自己为什么我没有受伤。那么你认为是什么促使我们在某个时间点得出某些反事实，而对另一些则不然？所以我们谈论反事实时，认为它们有两个不同的方向。想象世界本可以更好的情况，我们称之为向上反事实；而想象世界本可以更糟的情况，我们称之为向下反事实。当然在生活中，向上反事实似乎占了主导地位。
And one of the reasons that we seem to do this is that these upward counterfactuals are helping us learn. So if you think about getting into a car accident, if I say, you know, if only I hadn't been texting, then I might not have had the accident. That's identifying a particular cause of the accident. It was the texting and not my speed or the fact that it was raining or the way that the road was engineered and designed for traffic flow. And downward counterfactuals seem to serve a different function, which is that they make
我们之所以这样做，原因之一就是这些向上的反事实能够帮助我们学习。因此，如果你想到遭遇了一场车祸，如果我说，“你知道，要是我当时没有发短信，我就不会发生车祸了。”这就是在识别事故的一个特定原因。罪魁祸首是发短信，而不是我的车速、下雨的天气，或者道路交通流量的设计与规划。而向下的反事实似乎服务于一种不同的功能，那就是它们使
us feel better about the things that might have happened. And so my collaborator, Soyan Rim, and I have found that when people are focused on things from which they have a little bit of distance, whether that's things that have happened more distantly in time, or things that have happened to other people versus to themself, we're able to get into this mindset of thinking about what are the goals that we have, and what are the ways that we can use this negative event to self-improve. But for things that feel a little bit closer to us, so again, happening to us personally
我们对可能发生的更糟的事情感觉好一些。因此，我的合作者索扬·林和我发现，当人们把注意力集中在与他们有一点距离的事物上时，无论是发生在较遥远过去的事情，还是发生在其他人身上而不是他们自己身上的事情，我们都能够进入这样一种思维模式：思考我们的目标是什么，以及有哪些方式可以利用这个负面事件来自我提升。但对于那些感觉离我们更近的事情，同样地，是发生在我们自己身上
rather than to somebody else, those things we seem to be often somewhat more focused on feeling better about. And so with the example of your injury, it may be the case that it's helpful to think about how things could have turned out much worse than they did. That, you know, your back at work, hopefully you didn't need a lot of medical intervention or surgery, you know, and those would have been things that would have been much, much
而不是别人身上，对于这些事情，我们似乎往往更专注于让自己感觉好一点。因此，以你的伤为例，思考事情的结果本可能比实际情况糟糕得多，可能会对你有所帮助。比如，你重新开始工作了，希望你不需要大量的医疗干预或手术，你知道，那些将会比仅仅带着扭伤或拉伤离开要糟糕
worse than walking away with just maybe a sprain or a strain. So I'm reminded of that great study that Tom Gilevich did many years ago at the Barcelona Olympics, where he took photographs of the people years ago at the Barcelona Olympics, where he took photographs of the people who were on the the medal stand. And he found, of course, that the silver medalists tend to make these upward kind of factuals, and they tend to look a little less happy because they wish they had one goal. Whereas the bronze medalists tend to make downward kind of factuals. They imagine all the other people who didn't win any medals at all, and find themselves relieved that they find themselves in the metals podium in the first place
得多。这让我想起了汤姆·吉洛维奇多年前在巴塞罗那奥运会上做的那项伟大的研究，他拍摄了当年在巴塞罗那奥运会上获奖牌的运动员的照片。当然，他发现银牌得主往往会产生这种向上的反事实，而且他们看起来往往没那么开心，因为他们希望自己能赢得金牌。相比之下，铜牌得主往往会产生向下的反事实。他们想象所有那些根本没有赢得任何奖牌的人，并为自己最终能站在领奖台上感到欣慰
And this is fascinating because how this happens how we choose to make the upward counterfactual or the downward kind of factual This is largely happening unconsciously and yet this unconscious choice has an enormous effect on whether we feel happy afterwards Yeah, and one of the things that shapes particularly the metal example is how easy is it to imagine this alternative happening. So often for a silver metalist, it's much, much easier to imagine how close they were to getting gold. Whereas for a bronze metalist, the thing that's easiest to imagine is, bronze medalist, the thing that's easiest to imagine is, yeah, not being on the medal stand at all, because those are things that are actually closer. Another one of my favorite studies about counterfactuals is that if you think about a grade distribution where the cutoff to get an A is to get a 90% or above, students who get an 89 in a course
这非常迷人，因为这一切是如何发生的——我们如何选择进行向上反事实还是向下反事实——这在很大程度上是无意识发生的，然而这种无意识的选择对我们事后是否感到快乐有着巨大的影响。是的，特别是对于奖牌的例子，塑造它的因素之一就是想象这种替代情况发生的可能性有多容易。通常对于银牌得主来说，想象他们距离获得金牌有多近要容易得多。而对于铜牌得主来说，最容易想象的事情是，铜牌得主最容易想象的是，是的，根本没有站上领奖台，因为那些才是实际上更近的情况。关于反事实思维，我最喜欢的另一项研究是，如果你考虑一个成绩分布，获得A的截止线是90分或以上，那么在课程中
wind up being less satisfied than the students who got an 87. Both of them have a B plus, but the 89s, it's so easy to just imagine how did you get just that one more point, whereas for the 87s, they tend to feel lucky that they wound up where they are and aren't imagining how they might have gotten the aiminess instead. I understand you got married about a year ago and you applied some of your own research on regret when it came to choosing a wedding dress. I did. So I actually wasn't applying my own research. I applied work by Shineyanger on the phenomenon of choice overload, as well as work by Barry Schwartz and colleagues about the idea of maximizing versus satisfying as strategies for decisions, maximizing being the idea that you want to pick the best of all possible alternatives and satisfying being the idea that you're
得到89分的学生，其满意度最终会低于得到87分的学生。他们俩拿的都是B加，但对于89分的人来说，太容易想象“你怎么就差那么一分”了；而对于87分的人来说，他们往往觉得自己能落在这个成绩很幸运，而不会去想象他们本可以如何拿到A。我听说你大约在一年前结婚了，在挑选婚纱时，你应用了自己关于遗憾的一些研究成果。我是用了。其实我并没有应用我自己的研究。我应用了夏妮·扬格关于选择超载现象的研究，以及巴里·施瓦茨及其同事关于“最大化者”与“满意者”作为决策策略的研究。最大化者指的是你想从所有可能的替代方案中挑选出最好的，而满意者指的是你
going to pick something that meets all of your standards, but may or may not be the absolute best. So when I was wedding dress shopping, I went to a couple of stores. I tried on five or 10 dresses at each one, and I found a dress that I absolutely loved and was in my price range. And I realized that what the research told me was I would never be happier than I was at that moment.
打算挑选出符合你所有标准、但可能未必是绝对最好的东西。所以在我挑选婚纱时，我去了几家店。每家店我试穿了五到十件礼服，然后我找到了一件我绝对喜爱的、并且在我的预算之内的婚纱。我意识到研究告诉我的事实是：我不会比在那一刻感到更快乐了。
That if I kept dress shopping, I was going to wind up feeling overwhelmed. I could find a hundred different lace sheaths with a V-neck in ivory. And I would wind up feeling confused about what are the differences between these and that the very act of trying to get the absolute best would mean that I could never really be sure if I had done it. Whereas if I adopted a satisfying strategy, I could be sure I'm in a dress that
如果我继续逛婚纱店，我最终会感到不知所措。我可能会找到一百种不同的、象牙色的V领蕾丝修身礼服。而我最终会为这些礼服之间的区别感到困惑，试图获得绝对最好的这一行为本身，意味着我永远无法真正确定自己是否做到了最好。然而，如果我采取满意者的策略，我可以确信我穿的这件婚纱
looks beautiful on me and is in my price range and I should just buy it and be done. And so that's how I chose my wedding dress. So for all your kids who think that research has no benefit in people's lives, that's a great example. Amy Somerville is a psychology professor at Miami University of Ohio. She runs the regret lab where she studies when and why people think about what might have been. Amy, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Our team includes Lucy Perkins, Raina Cohen, Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penman, Parth Shah, and Renee Clarre. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Our unsung heroes this week are the program directors at NPR Member Stations
穿在我身上很好看，而且在我的预算之内，我应该直接买下它然后大功告成。这就是我挑选婚纱的方式。所以对于你们所有认为研究对人们的生活没有益处的人来说，这是一个很好的例子。艾米·萨莫维尔是迈阿密大学俄亥俄分校的心理学教授。她负责管理遗憾实验室，在那里她研究人们何时以及为何会思考“如果当时……会怎样”。艾米，谢谢你今天和我一起做客《隐藏的大脑》。我们的团队成员包括露西·帕金斯、雷娜·科恩、珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭曼、帕斯·沙阿和蕾妮·克拉尔。我们的监督制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。我们这周的无名英雄是全国各地NPR成员台的节目总监们
around the country. I just spoke to them at a meeting in Washington. Many of them are exploring the possibility of putting hidden brain on the air as a radio show starting in October. If you start to hear hidden brain on the air as a radio show starting in October. If you start to hear hidden brain on the radio, you know you have your local stations program director to thank. One last thing before we go, we're working on an episode about personality tests. Have you ever taken the true colors, the Myers-Briggs, or the Robin Hood morality test? Have you ever used a personality quiz to decide something important
我刚刚在华盛顿的一次会议上对他们进行了发言。他们中的许多人正在探讨从10月开始将《隐藏的大脑》作为广播节目播出的可能性。如果你从10月开始在广播中听到《隐藏的大脑》，你就知道该感谢你当地电台的节目总监了。在我们离开之前还有最后一件事，我们正在制作一集关于性格测试的节目。你测过“真实色彩”、“迈尔斯-布里格斯类型指标”或“罗宾汉道德测试”吗？你是否曾利用性格测验来决定某些重要的事情
where to work or whom to date? If you were asked to take the test at work, have managers used it to decide something important about your career? We're looking for stories that range from the silly to the serious and we'd love to hear from you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
比如在哪里工作或和谁约会？如果你被要求在工作中参加测试，管理人员是否曾用它来决定你职业生涯中重要的事情？我们寻找的故事从滑稽到严肃不等，我们非常期待听到您的分享。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。